Joseph follows me on Twitter at Dave
Ramsey Dave how do you deal with people
if they say it's not my job or I don't
care in your company well it's my
company meaning that I own it and I'm
the leader here I hopefully would never
have hired someone in the first place
that would say something like that and
so the first thing you would look at if
you're the leader is say what's wrong
with my hiring process that I'm hiring
someone that's that unmotivated people
sometimes say and when I'm teaching
leadership they say Dave how do you
motivate people I said don't I hire
motivated people and so the problem to
start with is is you let a donkey in the
building and you should have been hiring
thoroughbreds and donkeys and
thoroughbreds don't mix well now if
someone were to be in the building and I
owned the business or I'm leading the
business or I'm in charge of that area
or whatever and they say something like
it's not my job I don't care I we would
sit down and talk to them and say you
know that's not how we do things here
here in this organization that Ramsey
solutions we do care all of us care and
all of us in a business small business
by definition do things that aren't our
job all the time I'm not afraid to set
up chairs or help lift a box or you know
run across the room and pick up a piece
of paper that was law left on the floor
hi I'm not above that and if I'm not
above that as the owner and the CEO then
you're not above it so it is your job if
you work in a small business to
occasionally step outside of your job
description and do something and you
have to care now if you don't do that
then you are self selecting to no longer
work here because all of us that work
here we care and all of us that work
here do things that are outside of our
job description from time to
and so if you're not if you're not one
of us then you won't work here anymore
and that'll be a decision you'll make
and we would have a talk with him that
sounded like that and we would give him
the opportunity but if that kind of an
attitude persisted we would set them
free in Jesus name and I promise you we
would we're never mean or angry about it
when someone has to leave our
organization sometimes we just make a
mistake and someone's a part of our
organization that shouldn't be and so
sometimes they need to be somewhere else
and that's good for them by the way
because if you think differently than
your organization thinks then you're in
the wrong organization so you need to be
a play in a place and around here we
care now I guess there's one other
possibility Joseph and that is that you
work in a place where there are people
that say things like it's not my job or
I don't care and your leadership doesn't
mind people saying that kind of a thing
it's not countercultural to them and so
it's kind of like you know there's just
some donkeys in the stable and that's
okay well you've got two choices then if
you work in a situation like that the
good news is were you to decide to do
care and today it is my job and you were
just regardless of what they say you go
get it done anyway and you shine the
good news is is that it you know the
level to which the bar you've got to get
over to spent to stand out among a bunch
of donkeys is a fairly low bar I mean
it's the donkey bar donkeys don't jump
if you didn't know they have trouble
even stepping over a donkey bar that's
what we're talking about but now a
thoroughbred a thoroughbred can jump
they can leap and so it's a low bar for
you to get over to stand out and shine
in a situation like that that's option
number one is shine and what will happen
if you do that is one of two things will
occur if you'll go be excellent in a
situation where not many people are
you'll stand out and they will notice
you and they will you know you will your
responsibility will be
increasing your pay will be increased
you'll get promoted you may get promoted
to the place that you could actually do
something about this negative culture
that you're sitting in I don't know
that's a possibility sometimes that
happens
another possibility is is that you shine
among a bunch of donkeys and they don't
notice you they don't care they don't
give you promotions and extra pay but
someone else will see you a competitor
will see you a customer will see you
someone will see you shining and they
will steal you and they will give you
money because shiny people attract money
because there's not that many people
that do care there's not many people who
say it is my job there's not enough
people that do excellence in the
ordinary which is diligence and the
Bible says the diligent prosper so if
you do excellence in the ordinary you it
is your job you do care it does pay off
now is it frustrating all cried I mean
being a thoroughbred among a bunch of
donkeys is really frustrating and you
know what it's frustrating for the
donkeys because they don't like your
thoroughbred they don't like a
thoroughbred being around because
donkeys that have a thoroughbred around
your very presence exposes their
donkeyness they don't like it and it's
frustrating to them to be around
somebody who's excellent and people are
half butts that they don't like being
around people who get her done you know
they don't because it exposes their
their their lack of motivation their
lack of excellence their lack of caring
and you know what's interesting is
caring doesn't cost you anything caring
isn't he doesn't even require
intelligence caring just requires caring
you couldn't just decide I care I'm
going to treat this company that gives
me money to feed my kids and by
electricity and shelter for my family
I'm going to treat this company like I
own it
I'm going to care I'm going to focus I'm
going to be excellent I'm gonna bring
good ideas I'm gonna call out bad ideas
I'm gonna care it's going to be
frustrating I got to tell you even when
you're on it it's frustrating it's hard
if you think is easy you having a
conversation with the marketplace you're
confused because the marketplace is a DD
it's all over the place anyway it tells
you one thing one minute the next thing
the next minute and some of these voices
are so loud and they and there's only
two of them you know instead two hundred
thousand but they're so loud that sounds
like there's 200,000 people griping so
you know you know sometimes you just
don't know but you know all you gotta do
is care just care just care doesn't cost
a thing you don't have to have a college
degree to care you don't have to have a
4.0 GPA to care you don't have to have a
Mensa level IQ to care you don't have to
have been raised by perfect parents to
care you you don't have to be white or
black or fat or skinny or short or old
or young to care you can just decide to
care and you'll stand out you'll stand
out and someone will hire you someone
will steal you if you'll just care see
that's the thing Joseph it's a powerful
question you ask how do you deal with
people if they say it's not my job or I
don't care in your company well if they
they're my company we first would do a
little bit of self inspection and say
how did they get in the building in the
first place
because we try to keep all the donkey
doors shut we only want the thoroughbred
doors open we don't want them in here in
the first place so we got a hiring
process that led a donkey in how'd that
happen and once we did then once we self
assess and figured out how we made this
mistake in this hire the second thing we
do is we'd sit down with little donkey
and pat him on the head and say little
don't do you want to be a thoroughbred
because you're gonna have to care if
you're going to work
because the people who work here care
and those that don't care don't get to
work here so you got to start carrying
today or gonna be your last day will set
you free in Jesus name just decide what
you're going to do baby doll we're not
mean about it but people that work here
we all care because you people out there
listening you people out there that need
help with your money you matter
so we care this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh